how do I find my first client this is
such an important question if you're
first getting started up because your
business should be built around clients
you want to build your products your
services around solving the challenges
that your potential clients are facing I
got a question that came in from a
YouTube viewer love you guys
Jezz who way I probably butchered that
pronunciation but thank you for the
question 21 years old I don't know what
to do I finished college now I don't
know if I should go get a job or if I
should go work for a company or create
my own business I'm trying to figure out
what's my next step what's the best way
to target clients is handing out
business cards effective I get the
frustration I get the pain and and and
if you've never done a business before
it's so scary and overwhelming as what
do I do as my next step what's my first
step to getting this thing going the
best thing to do to help you figure out
if you want to have your own business or
if you want to go out and get a job is
to start talking to potential customers
okay don't go out and pitch because you
have nothing to sell yet you haven't
actually done anything yet go out and
start talking to potential customers so
I forget what the is into graphic design
and photography okay so this is his
business figure out who you're going to
potentially target so if you're say
you're targeting entrepreneurs you want
to target business owners Google and
start talking to them find out what
their problems are with graphic design
and photography and figure out what they
need help with and give them some
solutions just call on people and reach
other people in your network and friends
of friends and let them know you're just
looking to start a business and you want
some advice you want some help people
are always happy to help
they don't want to be sold to but
they're happy to help and if they'd like
you they know you they trust you they
feel like you can do something for them
they're going to want to hire you or
they're going to pass you on to somebody
who might be able to use your services
so phase one is just go out and start
talking to potential customers ask them
for your help make a list of the people
who are in your network who are
potential customers who are say
entrepreneurs but also just the people
you know who you can ask do you know
somebody I could talk to I want to start
a business but before I do I just want
to get some feedback on it I want to
answer a few questions is there anybody
you know who I could interview and just
ask them quickly about it that gets the
ball rolling you're going to make so
many wrong assumptions about what you
think you need that will only be solved
once you start talking to your customers
I made a pretty huge mistake with with
my first business was a software company
and I built the feature the most
complicated feature of my software I
thought was was the I thought was great
that I thought my customers would love
but it turns out they didn't care about
it and I spent so much time with my team
making this thing and it didn't work out
now luckily I had enough other great
features in my software that were less
complex to make but that people actually
liked and used that the software sold
but the learning lesson here was talk to
your customers we could have been so
much further ahead if I just built the
stupid thing around what they actually
wanted so you're not going to have a lot
of success just going out and handing
out business cards and say hire me
because you'll even know what you're
selling yet and make it easy for
yourself because that's a lot of pain if
you go out hang up business cards trying
to sell yourself everybody says no no no
you're just getting rejected constantly
you're going to think this is this is
ridiculous like I can't even get my
first client how am I going to build a
huge company how am I going to make a
living off of this so make it easy for
yourself and make it easy for your
clients make that list go start talking
to people let them know what you're
doing let them know what you want to try
to build get some feedback see what
people have to say see what their
challenges are and there will be
opportunities that will open up that
maybe you didn't even think of that you
can start with them on there may be one
simple small little project and if you
over deliver like crazy you might be
their full-time person that they always
bring on and tell their friends about
and it'll take you in a direction that
you never even thought was possible but
you don't know that until you go out and
start talking to potential customers
believe those you watching liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it makes you want to do more for you and
please leave a comment under this video
I love seeing them come in and makes my
morning every day and if you have a
question leave it below I'll answer you
with the video reply thank you so much
I'll see you soon